now i've heard  there was a secret cord that david  played  and it pleased the lord but you don't  really care for music  do you  it goes like this the fourth  the fifth the minor fall  the major lift the baffled  king composing hallelujah  [Music]  oh  i did my best it wasn't much  i couldn't feel it so i had tried to  touch  i've told the truth i didn't come  [Music]  with nothing on my tongue  but hallelujah  [Music]  [Applause]  me  hi  [Music]  this guy's probably fought hundreds of  thousands of other super beings on the  other planets he's destroyed right and  we have to assume he's won i don't care  how many demons he's fought and how many  hells  he's never fought us not us united  you